ahora vamos a ver otro ejemplo la
sustitución
y en esta ocasión tenemos la integral de
4x cúbica entre x 47 todo esto
multiplicado por de x y bueno porque
vamos a utilizar este método de
integración porque no usamos otro la
clave está en que si nos fijamos en el
denominador de esta división tenemos su
derivada justo arriba por lo tanto me
suena a que tenemos que utilizar
sustitución y no cualquier otro método
de integración por ejemplo no se
fracciones parciales o lo que sea
entonces es justo cuando se nos prende
el foco y decimos vamos a usar el método
de integración o sustitución la
sustitución u y que no era ni más ni
menos que nombrar a una función de x por
lo tanto quien nos conviene a tomar y en
este caso como tenemos la derivada
arriba vamos a tomar a como la función
que no está derivada es decir la función
del denominador ésta va a ser nuestro
prospecto para un porque tenemos su
derivada acá arriba entonces uno es
igual a equis 47 y quien es de 1
bueno pues vamos a derivar de va a ser
igual vamos a ponerlo con otro color me
gusta este color y como sacamos dv
dv es igual a la derivada de esto que es
4x cúbica más la derivada de 7 se va
entonces dv es igual a 4x cúbica de x y
lo estoy poniendo en la forma
diferencial porque recuerden que esto
pasa si sólo si la derivada de eeuu con
respecto a x es igual a 4x cúbica la
derivada de la función con respecto a x
es 4x cúbica y bueno realmente lo que
hice fue multiplicar ambos lados por de
x pensando que esta expresión que
tenemos aquí de hubo entre de x la
podemos ver como una fracción de dos
elementos muy pequeños por lo tanto si
es una fracción podemos pasar del otro
lado de x 10 que al final me den cambios
muy pequeños entonces es mejor verlo de
la forma diferencial y entonces me queda
despejada de vdv es igual a 4 x cúbica
y esto para que bueno ahora es cuando
voy a hacer la sustitución está
integrada la voy a escribir todo en
términos de 1 y me va a quedar 4x cúbica
de x / x cuarta +7 esto para que se vea
mucho más claro que arriba tenemos la
diferencial de v y bueno este de aquí
era nuestra 1 es un y el de arriba es la
diferencial de completa por lo tanto
esto lo podemos escribir todo en
términos de v como les decía y esto a
quien va a ser igual
bueno voy a intentar ser congruente con
los colores entonces las integrales van
de amarillo y esto es la integral en
magenta va de 1 entonces es la integral
de d
/ y esto iba de color gris gris claro
qué color es este bueno entre 1 y
entonces me quedan gente grande de hubo
entre buque esto es igual a la integral
y esto es otra forma de escribirlo para
que sea mucho más fácil quién va a ser
ni integral esto integral de uno entre y
todo esto por la derivada de un y bueno
ahora sí quién es la integral de uno
entre ud y bueno pues si hacemos memoria
esto es el logaritmo natural del valor
absoluto y del valor absoluto porque el
logaritmo natural no está definido para
números negativos por eso utilizamos el
valor absoluto el logaritmo natural del
valor absoluto de un la integral de 1
entre bv pues claro es el logaritmo
natural del valor absoluto de un y a
esto había que sumarle la constante de
integración y bueno si nosotros
quisiéramos dar respuesta en términos de
grupos ya acabamos esta es la respuesta
de esta integral 1 / v en términos de v
sin embargo nosotros queríamos una
integral con términos de x por lo tanto
nuestra respuesta tiene que estar en
términos de x y si sustituimos algo que
no tenemos ahora aquí es x 4 + 1 más 7 +
7 más la constante de integración y
ahora sí hemos resuelto esta integral ya
por fin en términos de xy por lo tanto
hemos acabado